un saludo a todos en todos esos rincones
del mundo en donde se encuentran el día
de hoy y cuando yo era niña en mexico se
jugaba un juego que se llamaba las
estatuas de marfil en este juego todos
nos movemos con libertad mientras había
uno que contaba 1 2 y 3
tras contar esto todos los que tenemos
que quedar inmóviles casi como
congelados en este juego el que se movía
perdía
ante la amenaza de este virus parece
haber ocurrido algo como lo de mi juego
de niño el 1 2 y 3 nos guardamos en casa
los negocios cerrados cerraron muchos
quedamos lejos de la familia el hogar e
inclusive el país
y donde cada uno quedó congelado está
viviendo una experiencia única y
particular imagino como una lupa gigante
que está magnificando intensificando
todos los estados emocionales las
tensiones familiares e inclusive la
violencia doméstica
mientras está loop apunta solo nos queda
mirar adentro y observar esos recovecos
que en la vida nos está mostrando
a lo largo de esta pandemia he podido
escuchar un sinfín de historias pero les
puedo decir que la mayoría están
cargadas de un ingrediente que es el
intenso dolor emocional
ese dolor emocional que pareciera un
monstruo que en ocasiones se viste de
una ansiedad incómoda que nos roba el
sueño y que nos nos quita la
tranquilidad que pareciera que nos lanza
un mar de incertidumbre en donde
perdemos la confianza el aseo y la
seguridad y tenemos miedo a no tener la
certeza de lo que la vida nos depara y
en otras ocasiones este monstruo se vive
como de un miedo casi paranoico de que
aquel enemigo del cobi 19 se cuela entre
nosotros en un apretón de manos en un
beso en un abrazo e inclusive hasta en
la bolsa del supermercado
no tengo duda que estamos viviendo un
duelo colectivo en donde muchos hemos
perdido la libertad de movernos como
confianza intranquilidad muchos han
perdido esa fecha anhelada de grabación
viajes y otros planes programados ha
aumentado el desempleo iniciaría de las
pérdidas económicas y muy muy tristes
están siendo las pérdidas de los seres
humanos de los de los seres queridos de
los cuales no nos estamos pudiendo
despedir
como consecuencia de este dolor
emocional aparece otro mal que es el de
la violencia doméstica que ha puesto de
manifiesto que frustración y encierro
juntos son una combinación letal
el banco mundial nos dice que en estas
fechas de pandemia en muchos de nuestros
países la violencia se ha duplicado
bastante picado en mexico las llamadas
que son por violencia doméstica han
aumentado en un 36% y por decir en
argentina han aumentado en un 25% es
indudablemente un momento de pico de
dolor emocional junto a esto aparece un
ingrediente que es el de la desesperanza
que contribuye de forma importante a la
aireación suicida ya teníamos 800.000
suicidios al año a nivel mundial que
estará pasando el día de hoy
lo cierto es que la tarea no va a
terminar un día una vez que se levante
la cuarentena tendremos que volver a la
vida como no la conocíamos antes y
además por un tiempo indefinido no
tendremos la certeza de que ese enemigo
del joven 19 haya desaparecido por
completo volveremos a una realidad
diferente en donde prevalecerá el
distanciamiento social el uso de
cubrebocas y cubrebocas
los desinfectantes y seguramente el
miedo al contagio seguiremos teniendo
que lidiar con este monstruo del dolor
emocional
sin embargo en una nota un poco más
esperanzadora les puedo decir que los
años que tengo trabajando con el dow con
dolor emocional y me he dado cuenta y
tengo la certeza de que todos venimos a
esta vida con una serie de realmente de
herramientas para hacerle frente
hace unos años atendía a una mujer que
había sido secuestrada y me comentó que
al ser liberada una de las cosas que
reflexiono fue que le habían podido
robar la libertad física más nunca la
libertad mental para mí fue una lección
de vida y me dejó ver que siempre somos
libres de elegir y aún es la diversidad
y aún en esas instituciones que no
escogemos somos libres de elegir cómo
vivirlas
otra herramienta que viene de la cultura
hawaiana en hawai el surf más que un
deporte es un ritual de vida los
hawaianos saben que tienen que volverse
maestros de la oval cola porque esto es
cambiante e impredecible y han aprendido
que es más fácil nadar con la ola que
contra ella
entonces para aprender nosotros a
navegar ya nada a esa hora de la vida
tenemos que mostrar su ficción
suficiente flexibilidad y adaptabilidad
para nadar tula duele más duele menos
adaptarte que adaptarse que resistirse y
duele menos aceptar que mirar
si me imagino también como un vaso
emocional y si en este momento tu vaso
de emocional parece que rebosa
posiblemente es porque ya venía cargado
en nuestras culturas latinas existe otro
mal que es el de la codependencia en
donde tendemos a responsabilizar a los
demás por lo que nos ocurre en nosotros
les puedo decir que el viaje de la ira
es un viaje personal en donde tenemos
siempre la responsabilidad de
autorregularnos recurriendo a la
meditación al ejercicio a una siesta
inclusive al de alto si esto es
necesario en la medida que nosotros
regulamos tendremos menos a descargar en
los demás
en los 20 años que tengo haciendo labor
de prevención del suicidio y escuchando
historias cargadas de dolor les puedo
decir que el dolor es una experiencia
humana es como un precio que vamos a
pagar todos por esta experiencia que se
llama vida el todos vamos a experimentar
ciertas dosis de dolor emocional
cuando lo abrazamos lo entendemos y lo
atravesamos y nos damos cuenta que el
dolor tiene un potencial de ser maestro
y transformador
el dolor siempre es un catalizador de
cambio el dolor nos muestra la oscuridad
pero también nos muestra la luz y por lo
tanto no temamos este momento de intenso
dolor emocional y mientras éste pasa
trabajemos en nosotros
cuando la vida nos vuelve a contar
1 2 y 3 esta vez no se encuentra
transformados